so what we'll be covering
um so we're going to cover what our
micro VMS first and foremost then we're
going to cover
um how you know why should you care
about microverbs and maybe you don't but
you might care depending on the use
cases
then we're going to talk about how do
you actually use the micro VMS so we'll
cover a couple of Open Source
implementations and then we were going
to have a demo if we had time but now
I'm not on my laptop we won't be able to
have a demo but if anyone's interested
uh you know grab me afterwards
so let me talk I'm showing my age here
but we're going to do a bit like Road
Runner and I'm going to talk quickly so
apologies in advance
so a quick show of hands um who has
heard of micro VMS
nice cool Has anyone used micro VMS
one good
um well did you use uh firecracker
hypervisor
yeah cool
well that's that's more than normal so
what actually are micro VMS so I'm going
to start with the word micro VM so that
that implies a lot of things
so with the first part the micro part
that that sort of indicates something
very small and people when people see
that that they make certain assumptions
about you know this thing is very very
small
and it's an adjective so if we're
talking about English you know it's a
modifier World it indicates something
about a noun so the thing that follows
it so what we're saying here is the noun
is the VM part so everyone knows that is
an acronym for virtual machine so
virtualize or emulated computer system
so when we take these two things
together
it's a question for everyone does a
micro VM equal a very small
virtualize or emulated compute system
the word implies it
um and actually the answer is not
necessarily so this is where a lot of
people you know think uh the thing that
goes wrong so this was actually pointed
out to me
um
helpfully on Twitter uh when I posted
something about micro VMS whilst I don't
agree with both of the comments there I
actually agree with the sentiment of the
first comment if I'm running the
kubernetes node in a micro VM is it
actually micro
probably not
um
but I much prefer someone else's comment
that like in liquid metal to the T-1000
so that you know that was a lot better
for me
so I've said you know what micro VMS are
not so they're not very small
lightweight virtual machines so what
actually are they
first and foremost
if you take one thing away from this
talk it's just lightweight
virtualization that's all it is
and what this really means is it's the
minimal minimal vmm that utilizes KVM
and when we talk about micro VM
implementations they normally focus on
or prioritize three areas in their
implementation
so the first is security
they want a smaller attack surface so
there's less vulnerabilities and
depending on your implementation this
this may include things like c groups
set comp filters and things like that
secondly they're designed to be fast
now if you you look into micro VMS
you'll see all sorts of numbers
published
you know this one here that is quoted
about firecracker less than 125
milliseconds to launch you know that
sounds really really good
um you know if I saw that'd be like yeah
that's amazing and that's to Launch
the firecracker process that is not to
boot your guest OS that is on top of
this so it's
so take those numbers with a pinch of
salt
but they are designed to launch hundreds
of these micro VMS every second per host
and there's reasons for that
the third area they prioritize is
efficiency and scalability
now what this really means is the
resource overhead per VM
should be minimal and in most
implementations currently out there this
is less than five megabytes per VM
so they try and minimize that
so moving on to the devices so what does
this virtualization support
so it's limited
that's where this micro aspect comes
into it so it supports a limited set of
devices or a limited device model
it doesn't try to emulate all the things
and be a general virtualization solution
it's not that it uses power
virtualization so the guests are aware
that they're running within a virtual
environment essentially you know
depending on your implementation there
may be varying levels of the oio device
types implemented there
but what this all means
is
there is less bloat less hypervisor
bloat is how it's it's commonly determed
it has a faster startup time
and
because there are less devices supported
you know there's less uh code in there
and less attack service essentially
so all of the microvm implementations
have a concept of volumes you have to
have a root volume to boot to boot the
uh the micro VM
these are all implemented as raw file
system files or block devices
and these can be really really
cumbersome to work with if you've ever
had to use those so this is where
overlay file systems come in or or Dev
mapper
some implementations some solutions are
built on top of microvms go so far as to
take a container image do some magic
behind the scenes and present that as a
block device to to the microvm
implementation so it sort of takes away
some of the pain of dealing with those
those raw file systems
now also depending on your
implementation
there may be no bios and no bootloader
the micro VM implementation such a
firecracker will start executing the
kernel directly it will go to magic
entry point and then it will start
executing from there so that also
increases the startup time or improves
the startup time
most implementations come with an API
server built into them and now this is a
per instance
API server and it's usually accessible
via socket now what this allows you to
do is perform configuration against your
micro VM so add a
you know network interface or a volume
but it also allows you to perform
operations now the operations that you
can perform depend on the implementation
you're using so it could be start stop
your VM or take a snapshot
also
depends on the implementation they might
have a metadata service built in now
this is super useful so this allows you
to place information in from the host
into the metadata service and have that
information available in the guest now
this is commonly used for things like
cloud in it so you can put your cloud in
it from the host and get it to boot or
use it with during the boot process of
that micro VM
a lot of people also use it to pass in
things like secrets so if depending on
your use case you might need a secret
within that guest VM so you can use the
metadata service to to do that
now moving on to why should you care
about micro VMS
so I guess fundamentally
it allows you to do more with the same
amount of tin so if we have a bare metal
machine here
and I want to run a a VM on there so
there's two parts to it so there's the
resources required for the
guest and then there's an overhead per
VM
now if I'm using the micro VM
implementation the resource requirements
for the guests are the same but the
overhead is less
so that basically means you know
I can do I can run more on that machine
and then if you think about Edge and far
Edge where the amount of compute is
limited this really really makes a
difference because it allows you to run
more things on that machine
so some of the use cases uh the big one
that is always talked about is workload
isolation so this is essentially because
you're running with the virtual machine
it's more isolated than a container and
now you might want to do that for
regulatory operational or data privacy
issues
so I spoke to someone that was
developing a
data pipeline as a service solution and
they wanted to allow customers to run
their own custom steps
but they didn't want to expose the rest
of the pipeline to that code that came
from the customer so they decided to run
that individual step within a micro VM
and isolated from the rest of the
process
you know this is close to my heart so
this is what we did we essentially run
kubernetes clusters or the nodes within
micro VMS and that allows us to
essentially have lots lots of smaller
clusters and potentially give one to
every customer or one to every team
instead of having you know a smaller
number of large clusters
and there are lots of other examples out
there in the wild some of the most
interesting ones are
you know using micro VMS to run isolated
build pipelines there's a really good
video of something called Alex Ellis
who's using it to run GitHub Runners
locally you know compiled kernels and
stuff like that that take forever in
normal GitHub actions runners
you can use it to create because because
of these the speed and the resource
requirements is a really good solution
to creating test testing environments
and preview environments on pull
requests so you can just spin up these
environments very lightweight
so how do you use
micro VMS
so essentially there's there's two main
implementations
that I think about as micro VMS there's
firecracker and there is cloud
hypervisor
they both have a
similar Heritage that both started out
for across VM they both use the rust vmm
crate
but depending on their use cases they
have now diverged slightly
there are other Solutions now so there
is the QB micro but there's disappeared
after firecracker and Cloud hypervisor
both support x86 and arm
and essentially what you have to do is
create an instance of firecracker or
Cloud hypervisor per VM so essentially a
process per VM
so if I move on to
firecrackers specifically
so this was used well this is used and
developed by AWS it underpins
AWS services so specifically Lambda and
fargate
now what this also means is it's
designed for a very specific use case in
mind which is a femoral compute and that
drives
the features that are within firecracker
and this really translates into a
reduced device model
so there is no PCI pass-through for
example
there is no Mac vtap support because
it's not required to run in AWS so the
features are driven essentially by that
what it does have it does have a
metadata service so I can use that to
you know do cloud in it if I want to on
boot
but because it's a femoral nature
it has no no concept to pause or reboot
so you know it's just a start or a stop
so you need to be a wary of that if
you're going to use firecracker
you can increase the security of the
firecracker process you can start
firecracker by something that they call
the jailer
and that essentially then forces the
firecracker process to be started uh
within a network namespace uh using
second filters as well for the system
calls
and um a secret to limit the resource
usage so you can really really lock the
firecracker process down one thing to
note is only you can only use it for
Linux guess
secondly there is cloud hypervisor now
this is a project started by Intel
Alibaba and a few other companies and
it's a more generalized virtualization
solution and it's a bit more
feature-rich as a result of this the
device model it supports is is greater
than firecracker
so it has a lot more vertio device type
supported specifically things like vdpa
if you're interested in that it supports
PCI pass-through
so if you have machine learning
workloads you want to run in your micro
VM is great
um
also if you use an sriiv as well this is
an option for you which firecracker is
not if you're interested in Secure
compute and enclaves it also supports
TDX and sgx as well which firecracker
doesn't
and it supports magnet about the box so
I should caveat that fly cracker does
have a featured branch open with vtap
support as well
there is no metadata service in Cloud
hypervisor so if you want to get
information in and out of your guest VM
you're going to have to use something
else so you can attach the volume
if you want to do that
this is whether it's a good thing or a
bad thing it supports Linux and windows
as guest operating system